fluffy blueberry and ricotta pancakes
with yogurt start by adding 125 grams of
plain flour a teaspoon of baking powder
a pinch of salt a tablespoon of sugar
then create a wet in the center separate
two eggs and add the yolks keeping the
whites for later beat the yolks into the
flour pouring in milk gradually to form
a smooth batter
[Music]
next fold in 125 grams of creamy ricotta
cheese and a hundred grams of fresh
blueberries
[Music]
now with your egg whites until they
almost reach soft peaks
then gently folding to the pancakemix
keeping in the air to make sure that
pancakes are extra light and really
fluffy and olive oil and butter into a
hot pan and spoon in the mix to make
small pancakes cooking into a golden
brown on both sides
to finish top with Greek yogurts fresh
blueberries and drizzle over lovely
runny honey sweet savory fruity and
delicious made in 15 minutes
perfect brunch pancakes my second simple
pancake brunch recipe is succulent crab
and mascarpone crepes for the filling
put cooked white crab meat into a bowl
add in mascarpone the zest and juice of
a lemon finely chopped chives and for a
spicy hit KN pepper stir and set aside
for the pancake batter simply add flour
salt an egg and milk then whisk into a
smooth mixture
[Music]
and oil to a hot non-stick pan ladle in
batter to cover the bottom and swirl
around spreading out nice and thinly
when lovely and golden flip over turn
out and spoon the delicious crab mix
into the center of the pancake and roll
finally sprinkle with some chopped
chives and devour
my second pancake recipe crabber
mascarpone crepes a fantastic easy
brunch cooked in minutes
[Music]
when you want your pancakes sweet and
zingy this recipe is perfect
coconut pancakes with mango and lime
syrup for the lime syrup simply add
water castor sugar the zest and juice of
a lime and simmer for ten minutes
to make the easy pancake batter put
flour baking powder and desiccated
coconut into a bowl then crack in an egg
add coconut milk and whisk into the
batter into well combined
sweeten with runny honey
now you're ready to fry add melted
butter to a hot pan place in heat
teaspoons of batter flip and cook until
golden for a lovely vibrant wake up sir
with sliced fresh mango and drew over
the gorgeous citrusy syrup sweet sticky
and utterly irresistible ready in under
20 minutes
the ultimate indulgent pancakes
[Music]